but in terms of the court of a public
opinion it would seem wise
just to not put that individual in there
basically the same fear that warner
brothers had with keeping johnny depp in
fantastic beasts for the third
installment is the same fear and
decision making that ought to be applied
for putting amber heard in the next
aquaman movie
[Music]
guys there's a flying here and we can't
get rid of it but it's here to stay hey
what's going on john and greg here today
we are going to talk about something
that apparently amber heard has
confirmed in her her latest testimony
just to get this out of the way we are
not up to date on the trial so we're not
here to talk about any
specific allegations or big revelations
in the trial itself we're going to
strictly talk about the business
standpoint optics all surrounding this
aquaman 2 situation that's going to be
our main focus and if you see a fly in
the frame enjoy that fly we call him
henry
henry
third reject henry we have an expert
here from the testimony when she was
being questioned here's how it goes the
lawyer asks have you participated in
aquaman two
and she replied i have i fought really
hard to stay in the movie they didn't
want to include me in the film again
it's a big confirmation according to her
that it's due to the fact of how you
know she's been called like a liar
there's been a lot of fan backlash
towards her the lawyer asked where he
ultimately able to film aquaman 2 heard
replied a very pared-down version of
that role yes the lawyer said what if
anything changed in the script heard
replied i was given a script then given
new versions of the script that had
taken away scenes that had action in it
that depicted my character and another
character without giving spoilers away
it's very kind of you just still not
still be spoiling it
that's what water would come raining
terror on here objections everything
spoilers everything else is fine but no
not aquaman not now her her character's
fighting with one another they basically
took a bunch out of my role they just
removed a bunch according to what she's
been talking about is that a big part of
her role was removed from there now
there's been a petition that's been
going around for ages to have her role
removed there's also been other stories
that have come up regarding uh you know
did walter hamada actually want her in
the film walter hamada dc president
there was a three-hour deposition i
believe apparently what he was saying
i'm not sure if this is you know an
actual confirmed thing he said but what
all the reports were were communicating
is that it had more to do with her
chemistry with jason momoa that's a big
part of why he didn't want her to come
back supposedly and it brought back up
something before that amber heard it
talked about publicly where when she was
on set for the first aquaman movie you
know she kind of told the story like it
was a playful thing she would often be
hanging 30 feet high in the air because
there's a lot of wire effects that go
into these movies and so to keep herself
occupied she'd like to read in between
takes there'll be times where jason
momoa would just rip out a bunch of
pages from her book and she said it was
because he wanted to be the center of
attention have the attention kept on him
a lot of people perceived that to be an
act of cruelty but the way how the story
was being told also sound like it was
kind of funny so i i don't know i don't
know what to make of it my opinion of
amber heard in aquaman was i thought she
was fine and i'm not here to like insult
her and be like terrible terrible actors
i thought she was fine in the movie i
didn't think her and jason mamoa had
some type of electric spark or something
like that and that's just my genuine
feelings on it i didn't know much
chemistry whatsoever yeah i thought it
was kind of blank she's saying that she
fought really hard to maintain her role
there i'm really curious what she had to
do to maintain her role here because i
would feel from warner brothers
perspective from from the optics
surrounding it yes that whole thing
happened with the sun article so then
johnny depp lost fantastic beasts and it
looked like the court was in you know
her favor yeah okay we can keep her on
but now with everything that's been
swaying and switching around especially
in the court of public opinion it's like
i don't know how this trial is going to
end johnny depp very well could lose
this trial but in terms of the court of
a public opinion which is audience which
is the customers the people who are
gonna pay to go watch your movie it
would seem wise
just to not put that individual in there
basically the same fear that warner
brothers had with keeping johnny depp in
fantastic beasts for the third
installment is the same fear and
decision making that ought to be applied
for putting amber heard in the next
aquaman movie because i don't know if i
could just see the character mira i
think i would just be distracted and
there'd also be a lot of negativity from
you know social media especially for
your massively budgeted film your sequel
to your billion dollar hit film that's
the last thing you'd want for
press in the game of acting when
everything really seems to ride so much
on your reputation and how the public
perceives you it would seem wise to have
just removed her and replaced her now i
feel like i'm going to be even more
aware that when her scenes pop up
knowing that her stuff was cut that's
just going to be distracting now when
it's in the movie and i'm curious if
they pared it down in a way where they
could reshoot her out of it depending on
how this trial goes i wouldn't be
surprised if they if they did that it is
a fascinating thing to look at because
yeah they have to kind of weigh the
lesser of two evils and i bet you know
they probably do have the option if they
need to to cut her out or replace her or
something if this trial goes even
further down the rabbit hole of
nastiness because it seems like from
this perspective they've certainly come
out on the side of well some people are
going to be mad if we take her out but
way more people are going to be mad if
we feature her and build that character
up i'm curious to know what got paired
down and how but you're in a position
where yeah like no matter what her
presence or her absence is going to loom
over the movie and is going to be a
distraction and so now it's about the
damage control of which is worse you
know it's like you said it's all about
public perception it's all about you
know the court of public opinion
especially when it comes to these movies
and it's an interesting thing to look at
because you know they're not making
these decisions due to morality or due
to like oh we gotta be in line with the
law or whatever verdict the public you
know has delivered down to them for them
it's about how do we minimize the amount
of backlash and the amount of you know
boycotting and protesting this movie and
it seems like the fact of the matter is
while there are certainly people who
stand with amber hurt and who are very
dedicated to her side of the story those
people are not going to be as numerous
and as detrimental to the box office as
the johnny team it's a strange
unfortunate position and yeah for an
actor it's like you know this is the
biggest opportunity she's ever had and
it doesn't seem like people were keen on
her in that role to begin with but now
it just seems like nothing good can come
of any of this yeah i mean she's not a
big part of the movie i can look past it
to be totally upfront with you guys i
can go watch aquaman 2 and probably
still enjoy the movie for what it is and
just be temporarily distracted by that
amber heard on screen
so i'm not going to be sitting there in
like fury especially since they've
already come this far however you know
it is everything about a movie's release
often
relies on
the
anticipation factor the hype factor
having her there even if it's a minimal
role still would cause
a lot of outrage
yeah it tests the theory yeah they say
you know all press is good press but in
this case i don't think that's
necessarily the truth you know just a
genuine curiosity is how many people
would indeed boycott the film how many
people would indeed not go watch this
movie simply because she's in it i don't
know how much i've upset people but
being like yeah i'll still watch it i'm
still gonna watch the flash i'm still
gonna watch these movies even though i'm
like no these people should actually be
getting out of here they shouldn't be
doing any more movies for us
we shouldn't have their status and their
you know life bolstered and elevated by
this experience given what we know to be
true in the real world i'll still watch
the films and i think most will that's
my honest opinion i think most will i i
think there'll be a a very strong vocal
minority who is going to be so dead set
on not paying to go watch this film
which i get well if you want to do that
you just get an amc stubs a-list pass
you get three movies a week and then
just don't buy concessions you know
yeah
there are ways to compensate for it
get around it yeah yeah that's just one
of many
two i think there are going to be people
who on the opposite end of the spectrum
are going to go check it out just to see
the geek show of it just to see what got
included what maybe was cut how is the
performance amid all of this stuff you
know be honest i feel like you could
have replaced it right they did it and
the dark knight rises
for like way less you know controversy
than katie holmes yeah i mean that's
like a made-up character mira is like an
actual big comic book character
that's another reason why i feel like
you maybe ought to have just replaced
her we'll see how the trial goes i feel
like that's going to be a big
determining factor but what do you guys
think do you think they should just
remove her replace her with ray fisher
yeah that'd be cool
accountability over here oh yeah
booyah my man
carry my son
yeah you know
put some cyborg parts in there it'll
work out that's it today tune in
i don't know
well yep
we're done